attention is the common currency across
all business it's the most important
currency you can have attention comes in
many forms which is part of the reason I
studied it so much
there's the attention for if you turn
your head because you hear a gunshot
there's attention for if you start
concentrating on a speaker and there's
the type of attention that makes people
long-term fans of a company like Apple
or celebrity like Beyonce and so
attention has become more and more
important over the last especially the
last 10 years because there's so much
more information than ever being
produced in the last two years alone
approximately 90% of the world's
information was created and we still
have the same 24 hours of time and so
it's more important than ever whether
you're a teacher or an entrepreneur or a
business person to capture the attention
of others immediate attention is our
short-term and immediate and unconscious
and subconscious reaction to certain
sights sounds and other stimuli you can
have certain things that will capture
their immediate attention
certain colors certain symbols certain
sounds short attention is our short-term
conscious concentration on a subject or
an idea or an object it's the kind of
attention that you give when you're
concentrating on an episode of Game of
Thrones or you're listening to a keynote
speaker or you're looking at a news
article it's the type of attention where
we decide we're going to pay attention
to something and what's really important
about that is making sure that something
is it really focuses on novelty and
focuses on things that are new and so
long attention which is the final stage
of attention really focuses on that long
term interest in a subject person or
idea unlike short attention which is
focused on you know short-term
concentration or maybe an episode of
house of cards long attention is
becoming a lifelong fan and watching
every single season
it's rather than just buying like
listening to a Beyonce song on the radio
it's buying all our albums long
attentions about that long term interest
and we
focuses on what you're familiar with and
becoming really really ingrained with a
subject or an idea you have to think of
attention as three stages and you have
to capture attention by going through
the three stages immediate attention to
short attention to long-term attention
and we got to start with the first to
the second to the third and that's the
secret to capturing attention